So, now that we know where turtle exists within Python, I
want to return back to our code. By the way, I
had to reduce the font size of the code a little
bit, so we could see all of it in the same frame.
Now, what we have done thus far is, created an instance
of a class called turtle, we called it brad and brad draws
a square. If we can do that, we can make another
example or instance of the class turtle. And we can call it,
let's say, angie. There it is. Now, I want angie to draw a circle.
A circle of radius, let's say, 100. I also want angie's shape to be in
the form of an arrow and I want angie's color to be blue. There
it is. So, let me save and run this thing and see how it looks.
Aha, it seems we have brad making a yellow square and
angie making a blue circle. It seems like we are getting somewhere.